[Musique]
combien y at-il de plantes menacées de
disparition au québec 57
sans compter les mousses de ce nombre 14
sont endémiques qui veut dire qu'elle ne
pousse nulle part ailleurs au monde si
elles disparaissent du québec
elles disparaissent de la surface de la
terre huit de ces espèces précieuse
pousse sur les rives du saint-laurent et
sont donc particulièrement menacés par
la montée des eaux et l'intensification
des tempêtes
autrement dit par les changements
climatiques par exemple la gentiane de
victor est où les rios colons de parker
les zones où il y a le plus de plantes
endémiques menacées sont l'estuaire doux
bus ou l'effet des marées se fait sentir
les rives du bas-saint-laurent et de la
gaspésie sur les affleurements rocheux
les îles mingant et la région de blanc
sablon
à l'échelle du canada entier 640 plantes
sont en péril dont 42 qui ne pousse
nulle part ailleurs au monde